The Netflix horror-mystery show Stranger Things
has been praised for its pitch-perfect homage
to the 1980s, and that includes its great
opening credits sequence.
It plays for almost a full minute before every
episode, but it looks so good I never skipped
over it.
Watching it made me wonder — what does it
take to make something like this?
So I called up Michelle Dougherty.
She’s a creative director at Imaginary Forces,
the studio that made the title sequence.
"You want it to feel, original, you want it
to feel like that title sequence couldn't
work in front of another show."
You may not have heard of Imaginary Forces,
but you’ve probably seen their work.
They’re responsible for the opening credits
to Mad Men, Boardwalk Empire, Chuck, The Pacific,
Jessica Jones, Late Night with Seth Myers
— I could go on, it’s a long list.
When they first got on the phone with Stranger
Things showrunners Matt and Ross Duffer, they
knew they wanted to go for a style similar
to what the studio R/Greenberg Associates
did in the '70s and '80s with Alien, The Dead
Zone, and Altered States.
"The Duffers had sent us these paperback books,
probably ones that they read as kids.
We looked at the typography on those and,
you know, they may range, right?
But they're all kind of in the same vein of
popular typefaces of the '80s."
She sent me their early drafts of the title
sequence, and you can clearly see the influence
of those book covers.
The Duffer brothers picked this one, which,
eventually, became this.
Let’s talk about the typeface.
It’s called ITC Benguiat, and it was made
in 1978 by a jazz percussionist-turned designer
named Ed Benguiat.
Here it is on the “Choose Your Own Adventure”
book series from the '80s and '90s.
And on The Smiths’ 1987 album “Strangeways,
Here We Come.”
It’s also been the font of Paramount’s
FBI piracy warning since 1995.
I often think of the sequence as a celebration
of that typeface in a way, because you really
get to see the most beautiful parts of it.
In the old days before animation software,
title sequences were shot “optically”
— which is just another way of saying they
were made manually, frame-by-frame, with a
projector and a camera.
For Stranger Things, the title designers wanted
to replicate that gritty look; they wanted
to make it look like there were imperfections
in the image.
So to do that, they rigged up these things:
they call them kodaliths, it's basically
an old film format that produces a really
high contrast image.
And they filmed what it looked like when light
shined through those film letters.
"We referenced some of those inconsistencies,
what you call mistakes.
We wanted it to have this tactile feel … and we
wanted it to feel organic and of the time period."
They then used those
animate the titles digitally.
That’s why you see subtle flickering and
shaking in the text.
The end result is an eerie mix of digital
and physical mediums — and with this great
track from the synth band Survive, it sets
the tone for one of this summer’s biggest TV hits.